uh i remember seeing on on
on your channel the you were saying that
it's
these these are uncomfortable truth
um
why do you think it's so uncomfortable
because it's hard and it usually
requires you to do work so i mean if i
tell guys you know for example because
most women today find the vast majority
of men unattractive
if you take a look at the swiping habits
of women
on dating apps i think you've read my
book right
i'm sorry you cut off for a second there
you said i keep dating yes right yeah i
do i i'm sorry
yeah so i cover this part of my book so
this will be you know familiar for you
but
women on dating apps like even if she's
a three out of ten you know in the looks
department categorically you know if you
showed a picture to a bunch of guys in
the raider like a 3 out of 10. even if
she's a 3 out of 10
she's only going to swipe right on guys
that she's going to estimate are an 8
out of 10 or better
right so women think the vast majority
of guys out there don't cut it and then
when you tell guys that they don't cut
it because
their looks aren't right
they're i mean
what is it something like 60 of the
north american population is
categorically obese
morbidly obese obese you know getting
there like they've got underlying
conditions like diabetes and all the
other stuff that comes along with it so
most guys don't look good you know to
begin with but if you tell them you know
to eat healthy and lift weights and
exercise
and drop the poundage so that they can
you know see their johnson when they get
out of the shower sometimes that's too
much for them they don't like that right
you know you tell them to get a style
like some guys are just holding on to
scraps right i shave my head because why
you know like why bother holding on to
scraps or trying to you know pretend
it's not happening you surrender to it
you know and you move on there's a large
chunk of the female population that
finds bald men very attractive and sexy
okay well those are the ones that i want
to appeal to they they don't like bald
guys i don't care i don't need to deal
with you right so
like there's all these comforting lies
that you know guys will start to hear
and they'll and they'll jump through all
these hoops
doing things that they think will get
them you know results but they don't
and this is and this is what i'm doing
like i'm unplugging guys from the from
the bs like the first step in unplugging
is becoming aware of your own bs the
second step in unplugging is starting to
become aware of their bs
right and a lot of guys you know just
dealing with their own internal bull
crap is very very hard to do because
they were told just
let's just deal with a nice guy thing
like one very small narrow area just
just be a nice guy just be yourself
right you know you've probably heard
that at some point in your lives the
advice usually comes from our mothers or
you know some part of society that just
says you know just be a nice guy or just
be yourself and the right girl will one
day magically come along
yeah well i think i think that
for my
how i approach that
is
don't be arrogant
don't be
don't be stubborn learn to be humble or
at least how i approach dean
so let's talk about
arrogance
what else did you say there was humble
arrogance what was the third one you
know stubborn and kind of like you know
being the type of person that that
doesn't examine his own life in a way
that
allows himself to
judge his character and the errors that
he needs to improve okay and so yeah
so let's just hit on those traits
because what you're talking about is
you're starting to lean into like dark
dark triad traits is what they're often
called or disagreeableness but i mean
here's the interesting thing about being
more disagreeable and women on
personality traits are more often not
more agreeable and
strong alpha high testosterone cues men
are more disagreeable and guess what
these guys make more money they have
more access to women you know their
entire life uh they generally have a
better standard of living i mean you go
right down the list but the more
disagreeable you are as a guy and i'm
not talking like you know the
narcissistic like psychopathy sort of
corner of the dark end of that spectrum
but
the more you lean into
being more disagreeable the better a
life you'll have as a guy
not agreeing with the norm not complying
with the nonsense that they tell you to
do that serves their agenda and their
narrative that's what the whole point of
this of this concept of mental point of
origin really means is are you putting
yourself first when you make decisions
when people tell you what to do when
they're advising you on this side or the
other thing are you saying yourself
okay does this serve me how does this
serve me how does this serve the people
in my inner perimeter you know the
circle that i love sort of thing and
then you decide for yourself okay well
if it doesn't then i'm just not going to
do those things
so that basically examining the intent
and intention you know the intense
intentions of your decisions and how it
affects not only yourself but your inner
circle that's what allows you to keep
your integrity and your heart pure
uh
sure i mean like that's one way to look
at it um you know the you know the pure
heart narrative but um
it's really just putting yourself first
man you know it's it's it's doing what's
right for you it's doing what's right
for your family doing what's right for
the people that you love that you've
drawn a perimeter around to protect
that's what matters you know that's
that's in my estimation what matters the
problem is is you know we're not told
that today we're told to follow this
uh globalist narrative of everybody's
equal
you know let's be more inclusive
and that's and that's how we
you know have arrived at this place
today where
you know
words are violence now today you know
when i was a kid we could go to the
schoolyard in grade four or five and
some guy you know was goofing off you
know causing problems and you'd be like
ah
you know timmy's and you just
kind of walk away
you can't use that word today
you can't you know generally speaking
because that's you know because that's
violence because you know i'm i'm in the
dark california
you might have like
a sibling that's on the spectrum that
might be offended by that right of
course yeah i've stumbled across that
already i live in california and a
friend of mine said that at a party and
someone at the party got really upset so
it was uh imagine that right
yeah oh
i can see where you're coming from there
and uh for me the reason that i'm
talking about the intention of one's
heart and
you know being humble and
learning not to be arrogant and i can i
can relate to what you're talking about
being
on the
on the side of being disagreeable and
how that allows you to
not align with the lies if you're
disagreeing with the laws
right for sure for sure you know like i
should have the right to choose to do
things as long as i'm not hurting
anybody
and uh being on a i would say blue state
i think is what it is you know more of a
liberal state in california i've
stumbled across this
this need to have to to be able to
socialize with people i have to have
more of an open mind and having an open
mind just forces you to
view these realities
but for me it's all right how do i
accept
what you're saying
and respect your point of view
without it
being a part of me
and you know i respect your point of
view i understand what you're saying i
don't agree with it and that's okay yes
you said you do you i do me as long as
you're not hurting me as long as you're
not hurting anyone
then we're good um
that is something that i strive for in
my life in terms of being a good guy or
a good person in in terms of how i
approach
my interactions with other individuals
is starting from the premise of respect
first and in the moment that respect
is this cross
then you know then we're going to have
issues
you